on découvre chaque jour que la
destruction de mario paul est encore
pire que la veille on ne s'habitue pas
ces images de guerre mais ce qui ne peut
fuir les bombes sont forcés de
s'habituer à vivre dans les ruines
voulais tout
donner ce qu'on traite à bunia mamie à
deux fois avant la guerre la ville
portuaire comptait quatre cent mille
habitants selon le maire de mario paul
170 mille personnes sont maintenant
forcés de vivre comme ça dans les ruines
de leur demeure sans nourriture ni eau
sans chauffage ni électricité
des dizaines de milliers de citoyens ont
fui à leurs risques et périls car les
russes tire aussi sur des voitures
conduites par des civils maj gros
pavé les temps dans la voiture avec son
ami qui est enterrée près de son garage
mario paul est en train de devenir une
immense cimetière les gens enterrent
leurs proches près de chez eux craignant
de trop s'éloigner les convois dead se
font toujours attendre les un corridor
humanitaire doit ouvrir demain
cet employé de la croix rouge explique
qu'il vient d'arriver à zaporizhya à 230
km de mario paul et qu'ils souhaitent
venir en aide rapidement aux habitants
de la ville martyre rieuse le jeu sur le
front politique
vladimir poutine menace de cushing
l'envoi de gaz à l'europe si ces pays et
refuse de payer la russie en robotique
si ces paiements ne sont pas faits
dit-il nous allons considérer comme un
défaut de paiement et agir en
conséquence du vote reagan de choc
beaudet casse le chancelier allemand son
pays dépend largement du gaz russe
affirme qu'il ne cédera pas ce chantage
poutine ne réussit pas depuis cinq
semaines à affaiblir le front commun des
pays de l'otan mais sur le terrain les
bombes russes continuent leur
destruction
les soldats ukrainiens sont fiers
d'avoir repris la petite ville de
toscane est même s'ils l'ont trouvée
complètement détruite après 30 jours de
bombardements